oh nope
i didn't do it that time i got a full
snout full
okay no let me just try to get them a
little rusty all you got to do just
close the old nostaroni and then oh boy
i got more that time
[Applause]
where did you get this
[Music]
i hope you get hit by a truck and a dog
takes a dump on your face nothing to see
here just a little hypoglycemic rage
[Music]
everybody
okay the tree has been contained wait we
left a man behind
him one day well terry's trapped in the
break room forever only thing we can do
now is move on with our lives that's
what terry would have wanted
god bless us everyone
yeah
this is what happens when you're naughty
jake did i say something amusing to you
answer me you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
hello
my name is adelaide i like to report a
crime so we're just doing one of these
every day
oh you got it
i know you got it
i want my money
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
okay okay
it's just kind of difficult because of
the deflating oh no
turn on the puck i'm very claustrophobic
tell me literally everything everyone
shut up
what the hell boyle you almost killed me
i'm not going out in a stool making
accident terry's gonna die saving the
president or terry's never gonna die
huh
what uh
nothing let's make out
ah all right hey yeah do you guys play
an instrument you know i play a little
bit of bazooka anybody else play an
ancient stringed instrument no you guys
want to go to the beach beautiful day
just maybe like get out there throw the
disc around right hey have you ever been
to the statue of liberty captain have
you have you been inside like under the
skirt like what's up there did they
build a you know what i'm saying oh guys
watch this i'm gonna juggle no no no no
no no no no no no no you drown in a tub
i hope you have annual semester aneurysm
after aneurysm
she'll be okay
darn it to heck the store is closed
oh are there bars on the window yeah why
would once fake her own death the same
reason she visits mexico once a year and
sucks the blood from all the goats for
kicks terry call it in the air heads or
tails
neither
oh my god did you just fold my quarter
in half
getting caught in the rain
printer's fixed
hmm oh damn
[Music]
good job can you do it without screaming
pro
bub lee wait a minute he's got a pulse
no wait that's my pulse no it's his
pulse no it's both our pulses he's alive
i'm alive we need more time someone do
something i got it
tear gas
this is terrible you don't know what
you're doing adam sandler yeah that's
right i collect antiquities i'm a
serious person
uh-oh my friends my beautiful friends
on fire i have an
std will stop at nothing to get that
trophy i'll shoot you all in the face if
i have to
go team
you're a grand old flag
i have a very funny story about keeping
my eyes moist
[Laughter]
nope
still not getting our vibe man
[Music]
i do not have a problem if i want to
play crazy cupcakes i will play crazy
cupcakes
crazy is a difficult word to say in
anger but
i think i've made my feelings clear
we need ye
the only thing that's a little much
around here are your scrolled on
eyebrows yeesh
it's full naked
ah
what's he waiting for i want to see
where your hair starts to stop that's
fiesta
oh you got a band
[Music]
there's nowhere to run her off
you dropped me rosa and then you ship me
to new jersey first of all throw up
second of all how'd you get back here so
fast if you get a box wet enough it's
very easy to bust out of it no one asks
any follow-ups everything is totally
under control charles's pants are on
fire what boy off the space heater get
away from the space heater i don't know
where it is i'm just gonna run at full
speed
curse my beautiful bubble butt see all
blue men are blessed with a flat ass
now
okay i know you have two bullet wounds
in your butt but you've got to stop
calling them your buttholes nikolas
nicolas nicolas nicolas nikolaj nicolas
we made a joke together
what the hell remember that very fancy
swiss pen i got you for christmas the
one that you keep in your pocket at all
times it's a taser bro
oh no
oh
is it bleeding charles is bleeding
you're gonna have to crawl inside his
shirt and operate his arms for him it's
a ratatouille situation on it no it's
over
one more time
all right one more time
one more time
one more time
one more time
all right one more time
one more time
god this reverse psychology is a bust
i'm the body shh stay in character
[Music]
gratitude
she's doing it
[Music]
oh that was great i love being
independent
i have to go to the bathroom oh okay i
help you
shame
shame for the last five years all i've
done is give a hoot about you and what
you think gave a hoot about you as a
boss gave a hoot about you as a mentor i
gave a hoot about you as a friend she
gave so many hoots not anymore after the
way you've acted and what you just said
to jake i don't give a who what you
think and i really don't give a hoot if
you decide to quit the nypd so do it i'm
all out of hoots i'm hopeless
you guys are
the podiums
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off
well it was good to see you caleb send
me that info
you